all right people I literally just got
back from seeing x-men first class I
actually just did the bum review as well
and I'm sure you wanna know what I think
about so here we go um honestly I have I
have a mixed feeling towards this movie
but not for the reason you might think
um in my opinion by far this is the best
x-men movie I know it's like a big thing
to say a lot of people really like the
x-men movies but in my opinion this is
the best one it felt big the action was
big
the characters were big it was this very
larger than life story when you got to
the climax I found a lot of was invested
I thought no this is big going up
this is important stuff not just you
know physically you know people are
gonna die and stuff but emotionally
you're invested a lot and in terms of
movies nowadays that's kind of rare in a
climax to be that into what's going on
so this film does all that very very
well now the Reese I have mixed feelings
about it is because I'm an x-men fan you
know I read the comics and I watch the
cartoon and stuff um and I whatever
people have this feeling to this x-men
movie while it's probably the best
doesn't have any of my favorite x-men in
it it has all the boring x-men it's
about Xavier it's about a banshee it's
about Magneto it's about all the mutants
that nobody would really pay money to
probably go see they're either really
boring mutants or they're ok mutants I
mean they're not the people that if
someone saw they were any issue they go
oh my god see this one um and the reason
that annoys me is because they did such
a good job with these characters and
getting you invested and really making
this sort of like a badass x-men movie
this is a badass x-men movie they've
really been waiting for
Bucky there's none of my favorite x-men
in it you know there's a a Wolverines
not a star Andros mass star game it's
not star all the really cool badass
x-men are not in it with the exception
with the exception of occasional cameos
which are very clever by the way they're
very well done cameos they're very brief
but they're very smart um
so I guess what it made me realize which
I sort of knew but it made me realize
just how flawed the other x-men movies
are which I never loved a of the x-men
movies I always thought they were okay
you know it's it's cool for the
nostalgia hey that's that's Wolverine
that's beast great but this movie really
opens up to sort of what those movies
should have been they should have been a
lot more potent they should have been a
lot more epic
I think Time magazine said like about
the first one is very wild 'less and
that's very much how I feel about those
movies so they're there okay there okay
movies you know I don't hate any of them
Wolverines pretty bad but even then I
don't think that's the worst
um now with that so what makes it good
um the actors playing these roles are
great it's great to see Magneto's
background Kevin Bacon is the villain in
this and he's a great villain he's he
reminds me a lot of Donovan from Raiders
of the Lost Ark he's just sort of
playing all the sides so he can
eventually come out on top and I love
those kind of villains that's a great
villain and he puts on all these
different hats and I don't say disguises
but he's just always on somebody else's
side you know just for the convenience
and that's really great I guess his
great power which I don't know if he was
a comic book villain I didn't recognize
him maybe he is but it wasn't something
big like sinister apocalypse or
something which I thought was kind of
shame come on let's see you know make me
was not the only ones getting our big
one maybe he's in the comic I don't know
but he certainly wasn't one of the big
five as far as I know or at least I
didn't call him by the traditional name
um so so that stuff has done well the
action is very well especially the
flying see if flying scenes are very
like they actually sort of feel the
flight in there you feel like you're in
air so that stuff so we've wonderful the
relationship between Xavier and Magneto
is very well done the actors that plane
like I said are great what else it's
very much like a sir like a spy slash
heist movie which is fun again that's
always sort of what I saw x-men ABS you
know that they go into places they sneak
around and then when they're discovered
they bring out the claws and they beat
up you know that's that's an ex
movie you know where I thought the other
ones we're always just very prolonging
you know come on get to the act and even
when you get to the action it's sort of
safety action um but I said they got a
little better as it went on but then the
story sort of suffered so um so I like
it for all that stuff and it seemed like
I said there's scenes where they're
going to get the mutants and they're
finding the mutants and stuff and I love
those scenes where they're getting the
team together and you're seeing what
each character can do and what they're
like you know and that stuff's always
wonderful um it is not perfect there are
some things that don't actually there's
two major things in my opinion that
don't work one and one that's very odd
one is the way everybody treats the
mystique character and when I say that
everybody treats her differently but
none of them are appropriate for example
there's it's sort of weird those story
but they make it so that Xavier mystique
our brother and sister stepbrother and
stepsister a little odd but I'll buy it
if I could buy rogue is whatever a 15
year old it's like you could buy this
and and the thing about it is that like
there's her and beast in this have sort
of a love makeups are both blue I don't
know that they have served a
relationship and the way he talks to her
is that you know we shouldn't have to
look this way you know we should be
allowed to look normal
you know and he's working on CM so that
they can still be mutants but look
normal and anytime she turns blue he's
like oh that's unnatural that's not
right and then when she turns human see
that's beautiful who would say that what
decent human being would say they're
decent mutant all the more reason what
decent mutant would say that and Xavier
her own brother does the same thing she
when she's all blue she says you know
Charles would you take me and he's like
oh what's the question was acquit and
I'm like dude this is supposed to be a
nice guy this charming nice guy why
would he be such an evil to his own
sister who when they were kids said
while you're magnificent you're
beautiful inside like what's changed and
they never really go into that and then
there's I think people know what's gonna
happen cuz
with magneto in the other movies that
she's gonna eventually go with Magneto
and the change you know how that happens
is explained a little but not much and
she explains to Charles I'm going with
him going to him and he's totally cool
with it what the hell it's like you know
this guy's a psycho he's gonna go crazy
above the law why are you just like yeah
that's what you want to do go ahead it's
it's fine yeah my brotherly blessing
that came out of nowhere that made no
sense and the only other thing the only
our major complaint is that this movie
goes really far out of its way to keep
the continuity to the other films that
this is definitely a prequel this has
come before the other movies and for the
most part they do a good job except for
about three or four major friggin things
and you know if you watch the bum review
you'll see what I'm talking about
um but there's one or two moments where
you just say wait a minute
that didn't happen no this doesn't add
up to this this doesn't connect this
does it and I guess maybe you can
forgive it but if it bothers me I
usually don't care about this stuff that
bars me because they tried to go so far
out of their way to keep the continuity
together and they even show clips from
the first x-men movie with the
concentration camp on top of that they
you know mystique was exactly the same
and it that really bothers me when
you're gonna go so far one way but
you're not gonna get some really major
plot points it doesn't add up and I
think it is distracting so that bothered
me it's stuff like mystique and beast
having a romance and then in movie three
it's like they never address I mean when
DC's they captured her I mean he was
never like you know me and her we have a
thing that I I mean it doesn't bear any
relevance here but um I know exactly how
her mind works I knew her when she was
quite young and uh maybe I could help
figure out what she's going to do but
she's just some chick I meet that's
never addressed the fact that I get by
the end you know again I don't think I'm
giving anything away you see magneto
with the helmet on and stuff like that
you know he's gonna be the bad guy by
the end of this um
but what happens when Xavier and Magneto
in film 3 in the beginning of film 3
when he's totally bald and he's ian
mckellen go to Jean Grey's house and
talk to it it's like what they put aside
their differences for a second just to
go talk to this one girl and then they
leave it's like well time to put that
put the helmet back on alright I'll just
go back in the wheelchair because I'm
paralyzed again what does happen when
it's so it's I don't consider that
nitpicky I do see that as a big big flaw
like I said simply because they went
back and they tried to really connect
all this together and if you want to
start over that's fine I want to see
another rendition of Wolverine I want to
see another another freakin Dhanbad you
know one that has more than a five
minute cameo you know I want zero done
right unless I see all these mutants
Emma Frost by the way sent this and
she's very well done they may be
essentially walks on again you'll sir
like this same feeling when you saw
Batman for the first time ever Wolverine
it's like no there she is
that's the character that's awesome he'd
be a little young but I think I'm that's
nitpicking but that was a very well-done
character I thought they they really
captured the essence of her um so yeah
and aside from little nitpicky things
like sometimes the helmet looks a little
goofy or you know like the yellow
outfits are kind of silly looking and
stuff like that that's that's really
good picking I thought this was a very
well-done film there are those two
really big problems that just as a film
it doesn't tie together but as the x-men
films go this is the first time where
you really felt like okay this is this
is really flowing and it's a long movie
it does not feel long at least it in for
me it really flew by and by the time we
got to the end I realize just how much
we've been through it's like wow that's
just I could watch more I could actually
watch more of this you know they make a
sequel I love to see it um I I just wish
they could they could use more of my
favorite x-men but again they're saying
this is a direct prequel so what are you
gonna do so like I said for me it was
kind of mixed feeling but honestly it
was very easily the best of the movies
in which I didn't go in with much you
know with high hopes I mean it just
looks like another spin-off with the
boring mutants and they made them
very interesting they made a very badass
and they made it like a spy film or a
thriller film you know with the
supernatural edge so I really really
liked it I'm sure there's people out
there that aren't gonna like it with
either it differs from the comic or or
again they want to see the cool mutants
so but with that said oh and somebody
was just tell me about mutant named
Darwin and I told him what happens to
him in this movie and he was just like
that is man so apparently not
every mutant gets the good treatment in
this um so some like I said I mean
purists are never gonna like the x-men
movies I mean because they do make so
many changes I've accepted the changes
it just got to be consistent so alright
so that's I think a prattle not enough
here I really really liked it and I
would definitely recommend it if you're
an x-men fan and even if not it's it's
still pretty interesting and they bring
up some you know fun little subtle you
know subtleties and stuff like that so
uh definitely a fun movie and that's my
two cents later